all these [__] 27y olds are like why
am I not a [__] trillionaire I'm like
cuz you're [__] 27 right or and they
get to play [__] game bar it's like
you're you're next to uh Dave pornoy
Parton my take Alex Cooper people who
are like you can't you can't reach their
level if you were to [__] hit the
lottery tomorrow you know what I mean
it's like so you or you might you might
but but I'm saying but sitting there
comparing yourself to them is not going
to get you anywhere and why didn't you
compare yourself to them long before
they were them
see this is what I'm trying to tell all
my friends they like [__] it you want to
compare why don't you compare yourself
do you know I mean I did it already in
this show do you know how many times I
[__] pound I worked in a [__]
liquor store at 34 cuz all these [__]
27 year olds are like why am I not a
[__] trillionaire I'm like cuz you're
[__] 27 right